[Music]
having the tour of britain come to pay
tour is massive people who come and
visit today and it's wet and windy today
they'll come back again to say you know
we went there once the tour was great
but they'll return yeah I'm really
looking forward to seeing the roads come
through this I came from years ago and
it's very good fun and so I'm looking at
brought to it today at team bridge we're
right on the front foot over getting
people out and about and leading an
active lifestyle and one of the biggest
and best things that we've had in recent
years has been cycling agenda today
we've been doing the school hill climb
at the final stage or the stage six of
the tour of britain it's four primary
schools and secondary schools they've
had the chance to cycle and the last
kilometer uphill what was great today
was that the organisers have given us
the opportunity not only to use the
course but to use the podium afterwards
which is you know a lifetime changing
experience something they'll never get
that opportunity to do again it sent me
a challenge for everyone to battle
through the rain cycling such a great
sport because is it you can get fit by
different ways because you're using your
whole of your body
to kind of keep it going and there's
lots of things you could do mountain and
road bike as well the first thing I did
when I was leader was instigate a
cycling forum so we're speaking with
cyclists now on a regular basis which
has led to greater delivery of routes
but with harnessing their enthusiasm for
recycling and it's having a dramatic
effect as everyone can see this cyclists
everywhere including up here on the
moors active mums if a group of
like-minded moms we want to get active
after having children and ride bicycles
and participate in all sorts of
activities well the great thing about
cycling is that you can do it in all
weather as you can see today and you can
deal with your kids in all sorts of
terrain it's easy it's simple it's cheap
and fun we are constantly looking for
the next visit for the tour of britain a
because it brings a great day out but be
we know that year on year it will bring
the people back to hate or back to Teen
bridge back to Devon
[Music]